the movie opens up with a chubby little
girl named Natalie watching a rom-com on
TV she appears to be enjoying the
romance between the lead actors until
her mother walks in Natalie's mother
mentions that she shouldn't waste her
time watching romantic comedy movies
because average and plus-sized females
like them never have Happy Endings
thanks Mom I'll just give up now the
movie then flashes forward 25 years into
the future Natalie is all grown up and
now she lives in a small apartment in a
bad New York City neighborhood she hates
the neighborhood because there is trash
littered everywhere Natalie lives with
her dog Baxter and loves him a lot but
unfortunately he never listens to her as
far as the neighbors are concerned she
lives next to a weird and arrogant guy
named Donnie who is always up to some
shady stuff for a living Natalie works
as a Chief Architect in a medium scale
firm however despite her experience and
position she is kind of a pushover
amongst her co-workers Natalie's
co-workers always make her do jobs that
are way below her job description like
throwing their leftover food out or
calling the IT guy to repair the printer
at work Natalie's only friends are Josh
and her assistant Whitney one day they
receive a new client a handsome
billionaire named Blake who has hired
Natalie's company to design his new
hotel Natalie is set to give a
presentation for the hotel's parking
garage but she is extremely
self-conscious and insists on emailing
the design instead however Josh gives
her some confidence and drags her to the
meeting room she enters the room with
her coffee and Blake mistakes her for
the office made to make matters worse he
drinks the coffee and instantly hates it
so he asks her to fetch another one
Natalie tries to correct him but her
boss makes her go grab Blake a fresh one
with no other choice she obliges and
Josh accompanies her to the shop along
the way Natalie pretends to be not hurt
claiming that she wasn't expecting to be
the star of the meeting anyways she also
says that plus-sized girls like herself
are always invisible to handsome hunks
like Blake being the nice guy that he is
Josh Comforts her and soon they return
to their office later as everyone is
busy with their work Natalie notices
Josh looking towards her at first she
she becomes excited that someone has
finally started to like her but when she
turns around she learns that Josh was
just staring at a large billboard of a
swimsuit model outside her window excuse
me Natalie I'm just trying to fantasize
about what I can't have Natalie then
catches her assistant Whitney watching
and crying over a rom-com movie at work
for the first time Natalie chastises her
and goes on a cynical three-hour rant
about why romantic comedies are [ __ ]
she asserts that the movies are filled
with lies because no one wakes up with
full hair and makeup the movie is also
depict that two women at the workplace
are mortal enemies which is obviously
not true moreover the rom-com movies
always have a cliche gay best friend
whose sole purpose in the story is just
to help the main actress the endings
always have a slow motion running
sequence and the lead actors are always
trying to break up a wedding or get
their lover back Whitney's like in the
time it took you to say all this crap I
could have watched two rom-coms having
had enough Josh eventually interrupts
her and asks her out for a karaoke
session but Natalie brushes him off
after Josh leaves Whitney tells Natalie
that he was asking her out on a date
however Natalie insists that Josh
doesn't like her that way because he is
always gawking at the half-dressed model
outside her window in reply Whitney
comments that more people would notice
Natalie if she were more open later
while Natalie is heading home via the
subway a good looking guy seemingly
starts hitting on her finally taking her
assistance advice Natalie decides to
give the guy a chance and tries to flirt
with him however the man turns out to be
a thief and snatches her bag Natalie
chases him through the subway and
somehow manages to knock him down but
unfortunately as she proceeds to run
away she runs face first into a pole
knocking herself unconscious later
Natalie wakes up in a hospital to a good
looking Doctor strangely the doctor
flirts with her and it creeps Natalie
out as she is not used to being head on
by attractive men after being discharged
she proceeds to head home but realizes
that New York City has completely
changed the streets which were filled
with garbage have now become completely
clean and the bad smell has been
replaced by a pleasant Aura of lavender
all the people outside are polite good
looking and she cheerful moreover a
romantic song is being played throughout
the city which doesn't seem to end
Natalie is speechless at the sudden
change and when she tries to cross the
street she is hit by a limo it turns out
to be Blake's car and he profusely
apologizes to her this time Blake is
more charming and he offers to drop her
off at home along the way he keeps
talking to her in a very polite town and
this makes Natalie assume that something
is wrong before parting ways Blake buys
some flowers and hands them over to her
but not before writing his number on
several of the petals Natalie thinks the
ACT is too cliche and that it is
impossible to rearrange the numbers now
but Blake asserts that when the time
comes everything is possible even
writing on flower petals after the
cringe encounter Natalie walks into her
apartment and to her surprise it is now
much larger and nicer she now has a
walk-in closet with hundreds of
beautiful designer shoes that perfectly
fit her the Arrogant dog Baxter is also
suddenly well groomed and obedient as
Natalie is trying to wrap her head
around everything she is startled by her
grand neighbor Donnie he is now a
flamboyant stereotypical gay man who is
acting more friendly than before
surprisingly he helps her get dressed
and even gives her a lift to work in the
next scene Natalie walks up to Whitney
and proceeds to tell her everything only
to realize that she is not her assistant
or friend anymore in fact the two are
Rivals and are constantly at each
other's throats confused and scared
Natalie then talks to Josh and
fortunately he is the only one acting
normal they go out for a walk and she
explains everything to him but as
expected Josh finds it hard to believe
however since he's a good guy he assures
her that he believes her and he will
help her in any way possible as the two
are talking Josh suddenly notices a
woman choking so he runs to help her the
woman is none other than the gorgeous
swimsuit model from the billboard
careful with the Heimlich Josh he might
snap her in half her name is Isabella
and she thanks Josh for helping her soon
the two get to talking and it becomes
evident that they are attracted to one
another Isabella invites Josh to a movie
and he instantly says yes and leaves
with her leaving Natalie alone as she
walks around by herself trying to figure
out what is happening to her she trips
on something and a handsome man comes to
a rescue he tries to compliment her but
it only freaks her out Natalie then
proceeds to curse in frustration but
every time she tries a sound bleeps her
out it finally Dawns on Natalie that she
is stuck in a PG-13 romantic comedy that
doesn't make sense PG-13 movies these
days say the f word and show balls and
stuff in this world strangers are nice
to each other and obese people like
Natalie are considered equally
attractive as others after thinking for
a while Natalie finally realizes that
she has landed in an alternate world
after she accidentally knocked herself
out hence she rushes to the subway
station to knock herself out again and
undo everything however all of her
attempts are futile with no solution in
sight she decides to step in front of a
train and commit the unthinkable
fortunately in the nick of time a
good-looking officer pulls her back he
however arrests her for entering the
platform without a ticket at the police
station Natalie gets to call a person
but she has no recollection of any fun
numbers hence with no options left she
decides to call Blake using the rose
petals he gave her earlier Natalie knows
that rearranging the numbers is
virtually impossible but when she throws
them on the ground they magically align
themselves Natalie is a freaking Rain
Man soon Blake arrives and bails her out
Natalie tries to tell him about
everything but he too doesn't believe
her frustrated Natalie then comes to the
conclusion that since she is in a
romantic comedy movie she must get
someone to fall in love with her in
order to get herself out that someone is
Blake therefore she decides to meet with
Blake for a dinner date and Donnie again
helps her to doll up the date goes
surprisingly well and the two have an
amazing night like in a cliche movie the
date ends with Natalie and Blake kissing
in the middle of the street under
Moonlight Natalie then takes him back to
her apartment and as she proceeds to get
intimate with him the scene immediately
cuts to the next morning Natalie is
puzzled that she didn't get to
experience the actual coitus she keeps
trying but every time the day just jumps
to the next morning Natalie eventually
gives up and Blake reveals that he loves
her however the this doesn't change
anything for her because she is still
stuck in the rom-com later Natalie goes
to work and to her surprise she learns
that she has to demonstrate an important
design today Natalie is obviously
unprepared because she doesn't know what
the hell is going on fortunately before
things get out of hand for her Josh
comes to her rescue he tells everyone
that Natalie is actually saving the big
reveal for later relieved by the narrow
Escape Natalie returns home and spends
all day trying to prepare her design she
is visited by Josh who brings her
Chinese food the two laugh and joke
together and it appears as if they
actually have genuine chemistry just
then Natalie begins to wonder if it's
Josh who she is supposed to fall in love
with to get out of the romantic comedy
however before she can say anything
Blake shows up and kisses her check out
this Alpha Dog Josh is taken by surprise
when he learns that Natalie is seeing
Blake so he quietly leaves the place
heartbroken and cocked the next day
Natalie and Blake run into Josh and his
new girlfriend Isabella at a cafe it
turns out Blake and Isabella already
know each other and they seem to have a
great Rapport after a bit of small talk
Isabella invites the couple to her house
in the Hamptons for a party at the party
Blake is occupied on his phone so
Natalie hangs out with Josh the two get
to talking and Josh reveals that he used
to think he and Natalie would end up
together Natalie has taken aback and she
asks him why he never asked her out Josh
mentions that he has asked for help many
times but always got no for a reply this
is news to Natalie as she was under the
impression that he only wanted to hang
out with her as a friend and not as a
date shortly after Isabella and Josh
gather everyone at the party and
announced that they're actually getting
married the following day this breaks
Natalie's heart as she has started to
fall for Josh that night Isabella takes
everyone to a nearby bar and challenges
Natalie to sing the latter accepts The
Challenge and sings I want to dance with
somebody she is initially underconfident
but soon everyone joins her turning it
into a full-blown musical number and
this is the part where I turn this movie
off the following day Natalie wakes up
to hear Blake pitching her idea as his
own to someone on the phone when Natalie
confronts him he shamelessly defends
himself by saying that she won't have to
work after she marries him he also
mentions that he expects her to take his
last name this upsets Natalie and she
breaks up with him as she likes being an
architect later she talks to Donnie
about it and also tells him about her
feelings for Josh seeing her feeling so
defeated Donnie Comforts her by sharing
his own personal experiences he tells
her that you can search the entire
universe and never find a being more
worthy of love than yourself Natalie
then comes to the conclusion that she
really loves Josh and must do the
rom-com cliche of stopping a wedding and
Nani carries on being completely
overlooked and undervalued wasting no
time she runs to the venue in slow
motion and interrupts the wedding as
Natalie explains to Josh why he should
be with her she suddenly realizes that
it's her who needs to fall in love with
herself and that is the lesson she was
supposed to learn after coming to this
realization Natalie leaves the wedding
steals Isabella's car and drives off to
explore the world that's it Natalie
please yourself at the expense of
everyone around you however her
exploration soon comes to an end when
she meets with an accident and Dives
head first into a wall the very next
second Natalie wakes up in another
hospital unfortunately this time the
doctor is older and normal when she gets
outside she finds the city dirty and
smelly like before which means that she
has finally returned to her normal World
elated Natalie heads home and becomes
happy to see her small apartment and
lame dog she also meets Donnie and
learns that he is gay in real life and
is also a weed dealer next she heads to
work and reaffirms her friendship with
Whitney but also takes a stand and
orders her to stop watching movies at
work Natalie then delivers a
presentation to her boss and Blake for
the parking garage for the hotel wowing
everyone afterwards she goes over to
talk to Josh about him staring at the
half-naked billboard of Isabella however
Josh demonstrates that he was always
looking at Natalie through the mirror
not the billboard great save Josh this
makes her emotional and the two kiss
Josh was still totally looking at that
billboard though later Whitney comments
that now that Natalie has made it to her
dream job and has a guy who worships her
it's almost like she's in an actual
romantic comedy however Natalie scoffs
at the observation as there's still no
musical number good but as expected the
movie ends with everyone breaking into a
musical number damn it subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching